[Music]
when the mobs came
they abandoned us good evening and
welcome to tucker carlson tonight the
nation went up in flames this weekend
no one in charge stood up to save
america our leaders dithered
they cowered they openly sided with the
destroyers in many cases they egged them
on
later they will deny doing any of this
they are denying it now
but you know the truth because you saw
it happen this is how nations collapse
when no one in authority keeps order and
when someone in our professional class
encourage violence american citizens are
forced to defend themselves they have no
choice
no one else is going to defend them they
know that now it's possible that more
people will be hurt in coming days that
would be a tragedy
but in an environment like this more
violence could very well lead to a
cascade of new tragedies
to something far bigger and more
destructive than anything we have seen
so far
so this isn't over it might simply be
the beginning we pray it isn't
it's hard to think clearly about
anything that's going on right now the
chaos the destruction the relentless
lying from above it's all too much
americans are bewildered and they are
afraid but most of all they are filled
with
rage angrier than they have ever been
the worst people in our society have
taken control
they did nothing to build this country
now they are tearing it down
they are rushing us toward mass suicide
so how do we respond
we must protect ourselves and our
families once again we have no choice
but to do that
but we cannot allow ourselves to become
like
they are we are not animals we are
americans
in the face of such indecency we must
resolve to be decent
we believe this country has a future we
intend for our children to live
and thrive here that is what we are
defending
all our leaders do is set us against
each other
they stage a never-ending national [ __ ]
fight for their profit and amusement but
we're not going to play along we will
love
our neighbors relentlessly in spite of
all of it not because they look like us
or share our political views but we love
them because they are human beings and
they are americans
those are the bonds that tie us together
the bonds our leaders seek to destroy
we can't let them we should start by
being unsparingly honest about what is
happening right now
truth is our defense and it's our
country's last hope
we plan to use tonight's hour to create
a record of this moment
right now to show you what's really
going on in your country we feel an
obligation to do that before the facts
are spun
into propaganda by the liars or the
images are pulled off the internet
forever as many of them
inevitably will be we're going to begin
tonight with where my family lives and
has lived for 35 years in the northwest
quadrant of washington dc
this is called mac market it's on
macarthur boulevard which is named after
general macarthur during the war it's
our neighborhood store it's walking
distance from my house
people meet there every morning for
coffee kids come after school for candy
it's as close to a community gathering
spot as we have
the market is run by the kim family the
kims are immigrants from korea they are
revered in our neighborhood for their
decency and their hard work
when they lost their son several years
ago the neighbors grieved for them
the kims are not political they've never
hurt anyone
they only make things better but last
night the mob
came for their store at 1 am this
morning mr kim was kneeling alone on the
sidewalk trying to salvage what he has
spent his life building
scenes like this played out in hundreds
of neighborhoods across this country
maybe yours
here are a few in columbia south
carolina a man called the police when
things began to fall apart
riders saw him call they surrounded that
man and they beat him
onlookers laughed as he was pummeled oh
yeah i know
everybody
[Applause]
in rochester new york a group of eight
men smashed the windows of a jewelry
store a couple who lived above the shop
emerged to confront them
both of them were viciously beaten with
a ladder and a two by four
[Music]
in dallas a man armed with what appeared
to be a sword did his best to defend a
business from looters
the mob bashed him in the head with a
rock and a skateboard
[Applause]
it's hard to watch in san jose rioters
with crowbars stormed the highway and
attacked
vehicles trying to pull drivers from
their cars
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
in birmingham alabama a local reporter
called stephen quinn was beaten
and then he was robbed on live
television as he tried to cover the
looting
that is the horrible
we're wanting to make sure that stephen
is all right
in portland oregon a man was beaten
apparently for daring to carry
an american flag in public he never
released the flag by the way
done with people like you're having an
opinion
how many of these people died how many
were murdered by the rioters
we don't know yet at the least some are
likely disabled for life
they were beaten that badly and then
there was the mass stealing it seemed to
be everywhere
over the weekend in buckhead and upscale
part of atlanta riders stole a tesla
from a dealership and drove it through
an indoor mall
just to underscore how completely out of
control things work in portland oregon
mobs looted louis vuitton
apple and chase bank among many others
they often set fires as they left
oh
[Applause]
in chicago protesters fought systemic
racism by running through a nike store
stealing shoes
[Music]
[Applause]
and in washington d.c a federal city
surrounded by military bases and
protected at all times by the single
highest concentration of law enforcement
in the world criminal criminals operated
with apparent impunity in the streets
they looted georgetown last night they
smashed the windows in federal buildings
they desecrated virtually every war
memorial in the city a week after
memorial day
and then as you likely know last night
they set fire to st john's episcopal
church
a 200 year old building that has
welcomed every american president since
james madison it's
right across the street from the white
house for people stuck
inside anywhere during this insanity the
sick
the elderly the powerless the experience
was terrifying
listen to this woman from minneapolis
how was last night scary
they went straight to office max the
dollar store and every store
over here that i go to i have nowhere to
go now
i have no way to get there because the
buses aren't
running so that's what's happening
in america right now we didn't play all
of the tape we have there's a lot of it
some of the tape is too shocking and
honestly it's too incendiary we
understand that television is an
emotional medium
and we don't want to make things worse
we're not going to but you get the point
the point is this is a national
emergency it's a profound
national emergency but you would never
know that from listening to our elected
leaders
almost all of them pretend this is not
really happening or if it is happening
it's just part of america's long
tradition of vigorous political
discourse
politicians on both sides tell us that
this is all about the death of a man
in police custody in minneapolis last
week the people burning down our country
are
protesters they're engaged in a
legitimate protest
okay what exactly are those protesters
demands
what are they asking for if congress
agreed tonight to enact their program
what would the program be not a single
person even hints at the answer because
there is not an answer
no one is bothered to poll the guys
beating up old ladies on the street or
looting gucci
but you've got to wonder how many of
them have ever even heard of george
floyd
and if they have heard of him what
difference would it make
violence and looting are not forms of
political expression
if you were killed tomorrow how many
buildings would you want burned to the
ground in your memory
how many old women smashed in the face
on the street in your name
none we hope because you're not a
vicious psychopath like the people
you've just watched
in fact what we're watching is not a
political protest it's the opposite of a
political protest
it is an attack on the idea of politics
the rioters you have seen are trying to
topple our political system
that system is how we resolve our
differences without using violence
but these people want a new system one
that is governed by force
do what we say or we will hurt you you
know this
you can see it for yourself on
television you have but our leaders
continue to lie they tell us that's not
true this isn't happening
it's just a protest some democrats have
openly embraced what is happening really
they don't have much of a choice
these are their voters cleaning out the
rolex store these riots effectively are
the largest joe biden for president
rally on record
in gratitude for that more than a dozen
joe biden for president campaign
staffers
donated money to the rioters in
minneapolis and then they bragged about
it on twitter
no democratic leader can directly
criticize what is happening right now
and in fact some have joined in
over the weekend the democratic party of
fairfax virginia which is an
important democratic organization
released the following statement on
twitter we're quoting it
riots are an integral part of this
country's march towards
progress progress
burning buildings tear gas dead bodies
the screaming injured criminal anarchy
to the democratic party of fairfax that
is called progress
celebrity after celebrity has weighed in
to agree on social media
from his fortified compound basketball
star lebron james has used his accounts
to encourage more rioting
bernie sanders surrogate sean king has
done the same so is black lives matter
leader deroy mckesson
colin kaepernick openly calls for
violence here's a quote
the cries for peace will rain down and
when they do they will land
on deaf ears he says approvingly
imagine shouting fire in a crowded
theater a theater with 325 million
people in it called our country that's
what they've been doing and have been
doing for days
when the violence began what we needed
more than anything was clarity in the
middle of this
it's hard to see when the tear gas
starts
someone in america needed to tell the
truth to the country
instead almost all of our so-called
conservative leaders
joined the left's chorus as if on cue
on friday as american cities were being
destroyed by mobs the vice president of
the united states refused to say
anything specific
about the riots we were watching on
television instead mike pence scolded
america for its racism
carly fiorina once a leading republican
presidential candidate tweeted that and
were quoting
it's white america that now must see the
truth speak the truth and act on the
truth
meanwhile k cole james who is the
president of the heritage foundation
that's the largest conservative think
tank in the country
you may have sent them money hopefully
for the last time k cole james wrote a
long screen denouncing america as an
irredeemably racist nation
quote how many times will protests have
to occur
got that have to occur like the rest of
us
caused this by our sinfulness the
message from our leaders on the right
as on the left was unambiguous don't
complain
you deserve what's happening to you no
one jumped in more forcefully or seemed
angrier at america
than former south carolina governor
nikki haley tonight i turned on the news
and i am heartbroken haley wrote
it's important to understand that the
death of george floyd was personal and
painful for many
in order to heal it needs to be personal
and painful
for everyone but wait a second you may
be wondering how am i quote
personally responsible for the behavior
of a minneapolis police officer i've
never even been to minneapolis you may
think to yourself
and why is some politician telling me
i'm required to be upset about it
those are all good questions nikki haley
did not answer those questions
explaining is not her strong suit that
would require thinking
what nikki hilly does best is moral
blackmail during the 2016 campaign she
compared donald trump to the racist mass
murderer dylan roof
how is donald trump similar to a serial
killer nikki haley never explained that
she wasn't trying to
educate anyone her only goal was
political advantage nikki haley is
exceptionally good at getting what she
wants
she's happy to denounce you as a racist
in order to get it
she just did in this case nikki haley's
wish came true the riots were indeed
quote
personal and painful for everyone and
then the pain kept increasing
two days after she wrote that dozens of
american cities had been thoroughly
trashed some destroyed
a country already on the brink of
recession suddenly faced economic
collapse
an already fearful population locked
down for months
had been thoroughly and completely
terrorized
mission accomplished let's hope nikki
haley is pleased we've now atoned
how did the trump administration respond
to the horrors going on around us
well yesterday morning the country's
national security adviser robert o'brien
did a live interview from the white
house lawn
here's how it began first thing i want
to say on behalf of the president he
said this the family
but our our hearts and uh and prayers
are going out to the floyd family
we mourn with them and we grieve with
them and and what happened there was
horrific and i can't even imagine what
that poor family is going through as
this video is played over and over again
that should have never happened in
america and it's a it's a tragic thing
the president said that from the start
and uh and we're with the family and and
as the president said we're with
the peaceful protesters we're with the
peaceful
protesters o'brien announced can you be
more specific about that who are you
talking about exactly
is it the people spitting foam as they
scream f the police
is it the one standing next to the
arsonist doing nothing as they set fire
to buildings
is it the kids laughing as they film the
looting and the beatings on their
iphones
maybe it's the famous famous people in
la who are raising money online to
support the rioters
they're all just peaceful protesters
yeah we support that
it's who we are what about the president
where was he
during all of this well on friday night
after the show leland vitter and a
cameraman headed to lafayette square in
washington to cover what was happening
outside the white house
here's what happened next
fox news reporter is getting chased out
by this
by the george floyd protesters here in
front of
at lafayette park look there's water
being thrown on the reporter
here hey look this protester just took
his mic
they just threw the mic at the reporter
here as you see guys
things are spiraling here quick at the
protest
that was in lafayette square in the
center of our capital city
and the tape raised a troubling question
if you can't keep a fox news
correspondent from getting attacked
directly across the street from your
house
how can you protect my family how are
you going to protect the country how
hard are you trying
on twitter the next morning the
president reassured america that he and
his family were just fine
the federally funded bodyguards had kept
them safe he did not mention protecting
the rest of the nation much of which was
that on fire
he seemed to wear only of himself for
people who like
donald trump who voted for donald trump
who support his policies
who have defended him for years and
years
against the most absurd kinds of slander
this was a distressing moment
the first requirement of leadership is
that you watch over the people
in your care that's what soldiers want
from their officers
it's what families need from their
fathers it's what voters demand
from their presidents people will put up
with almost
anything if you do that you can
regularly say embarrassing things on
television
you can hire omarosa to work at the
white house all of that will be forgiven
if you protect your people but if you do
not protect them or
worse than that if you seem like you
can't be bothered to protect them
then you're done it's over people will
not
forgive weakness that's the one thing by
the way that is not a partisan point
it is human nature nero is the only
roman emperor whose name most people
still remember
why because he abandoned his nation in a
time of crisis and two thousand years
later
we still don't forgive him donald
trump's response to these riots which is
ongoing
is the singular test of his presidency
about an hour ago the president
announced that he's going to marshal
all available forces military and
civilian to stop these riots
if a city or state refuses to take the
actions that are necessary to defend
the life and property of their residents
then i will deploy the united states
military
and quickly solve the problem for them
good for him immediately after that
address the president walked over to st
john's which as we just told you was
burning fewer than 24 hours ago and that
provided a powerful symbolic gesture was
a declaration
that this country our national symbols
are oldest
institutions will not be desecrated and
defeated by nihilistic destruction
we fervently hope this all works
what americans want most right now is an
end to this chaos they want their cities
to be saved they want this to stop
immediately if the commander-in-chief
cannot stop it he will lose in november
the left will blame him for the
atrocities they
encouraged and some voters will agree
donald trump is the president
presidents save countries that's their
job
that's why we hire them it's that simple
some key advisors around the president
don't seem to understand this or the
gravity of the moment
no matter what happens they'll tell you
our voters aren't going anywhere the
trailer parks are rock solid
what choice do they have they've got to
vote for us
jared kushner for one has made that
point out loud
no one has more contempt for donald
trump's voters than jared kushner does
and no one expresses it more frequently
in 2016 donald trump ran as a law and
order candidate because he meant it
and his views remain fundamentally
unchanged today
but the president's famously sharp
instincts the ones that won him the
presidency almost four years ago
have been since subverted at every level
by jared kushner
this is true on immigration on foreign
policy and especially on law enforcement
as crime in this country continues to
rise jared kushner has led a highly
aggressive effort
to let more criminals out of prison and
back on to the streets
this is reckless at this moment in time
it's insane
it continues to happen the president
seems to sense this
at times he seems aware he's being led
in the wrong direction he often derides
kushner as a liberal and that's correct
kushner is
but kushner has convinced the president
that throwing open the prisons is the
key to winning african-american votes in
the fall
and that those votes are essential to
his re-election
several times over the past few days the
president has signaled that he would
very much like to crack down on rioters
that is his
instinct if you've watched him you
believe it but every time he has been
talked out of it by jared kushner and by
aids that kushner is hired
and controls kushner's assumption
apparently is that african-american
voters like looting
that is wrong normal americans of all
colors
hate looting obviously why wouldn't they
hate looting
they're decent people so what are the
lessons
of all that we have seen and we've seen
so much over the past five days
america is going to change because of
this that is certain what can we learn
from it
what should we demand going forward the
first thing to know is that we can no
longer
accept race-baiting from our leaders
never
that has become so common now that we
barely notice it but it is dividing and
destroying this country we should make
them
stop yesterday for example mayor jenny
durkin of seattle
tweeted this and we're quoting i want to
acknowledge that much of the violence
and destruction both here in seattle and
across the country
has been instigated and perpetrated by
white men
quote is that factually
true who knows who cares
the skin color of criminals is totally
irrelevant to how we prosecute them for
the crimes they commit
it must be irrelevant otherwise
we are committing the bigotry we claim
to abhor
yet everywhere on television and social
media prominent people are now talking
exactly like this not just a few
crackpots
thousands of people well-known people
they are amplifying race hatred at
exactly the moment that we need at least
at the moment when it's the most
dangerous
this is art acevedo acevedo is the
police chief of houston houston is the
fourth biggest city in this country
acevedo's job his sworn duty is to
enforce the law
fairly and evenly regardless of the
ethnicity of the suspect
watch this and tell us if you think he's
capable of doing that
do you think he's even interested here's
art acevedo from over the weekend
my people for as an immigrant were
rapists
we know what we built this country
[Applause]
so if you've got hate in your heart for
people of color get over it
because this city is a minority majority
city
my people if a police chief
of any color any color said that we
would attack him
instantly and we would mean it it is
wrong
when you run a law enforcement agency
you don't get to consider
quote my people much less claim your
people deserve some kind of special
consideration because they quote
built this country no your obligation is
not to consider
your people but all people and consider
them
equally period art acevedo is not even
trying to do that
imagine being arrested by this creep
think you'd get a fair shake
there's almost nothing that hurts
america more than this if you're worried
about the rise of extremism here
and honestly you should be worried this
kind of insanity is absolutely certain
to cause it
and let's be clear when we say extremism
we're not talking about unconventional
views that get you bounced off twitter
or scolded by the corporate hr
department we mean
actual extremism where people espouse
violence against other people
where large groups come to believe their
racial identity is the most important
thing about them now at this moment no
matter what they're telling you no
matter what they claim for political
advantage
there's not a huge amount of that in
this country thank god
most people still think of themselves as
americans and want to but if the left
keeps talking like this
there definitely will be and very soon
and you don't want to live here when
that happens
we should demand they stop immediately
enforcing the law is not
white supremacy insisting that everyone
in the country follows the same rules
is not racism in fact it's the answer to
racism
it is equality equality under the law
it is the one thing we must defend and
if we don't it's over
things fall apart weakness invites
aggression that is true in nature and
it's every bit is true in human society
our leaders are weak predators know it
that's why this is happening if you let
people spray paint obscenities on city
hall pretty soon they are overturning
cop cars
if you put up with that they'll come
right to the front door of the police
precinct and they will burn it down
next thing you know they are beating
people to death in shopping malls
and then what what happens the next time
the mob
doesn't like something what will the mob
demand next
let's hope we never find out because we
are close